- My name's Gene, I'm 26 and
interesting thing about me
I am here doing an interview
with you right now.
- Ah that is interesting,
this is a great show,
and you're really
lucky to be here.
So what makes you the
most angry in this world?
- I would say online
selfies in bathrooms.
- What about that
makes you angry,
the thought that there's
shit behind that person?
- Yes and the fact that
you could've moved one room
over to your bedroom.
- Right move to that bedroom.
Speaking of bedrooms
do you want to know
what makes me the most angry?
- What?
- I hate when you're
making out with a girl,
and she's like
sucking on your neck,
and then it bursts a
blood vessel and it's like
I'm 26 years old baby, I
don't need a hickey you know.
- I don't know what
you're talking about.
- What's that over there?
- What?
(whistling)
What, what?